[تصفيق]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته انا
اسلام وراسنا كنت جميل كنت درست بجامعه
بلوتكنيك فلسطين هندسه حاسوب وانا اليوم
مهندس حاسوب في وزاره الاتصالات تكنولوجيا
المعلومات وبكمل ماجستير ذكاء اصطناعي
كمان في جامعه البوليتكنيك
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم والصلاه والسلام
على اشرف المرسلين سيدنا محمد وعلى اله
وصحبه اجمعين
بالبدايه حابب تعرفوا اني فخور جدا كوني
شخص من الاشخاص ذوي الاعاقه وسابدا كلماتي
باكثر مقوله امنت فيها في حياتي والتي
تقول ان الاعاقه ليست اعاقه الجسد وانما
اعاقه الفكر والروح اعاقه الاراده فعندما
تتوفر الاراده الصلبه يستطيع الشخص ان
يوظف قدراته ويتجاوز العقبات ويحقق
الاهداف مهما كبلت جسمه القيود فهناك
الكثير من الاشخاص ذوي الاعاقه الذين لم
تعيقهم اعاقتهم عن تحويل حياتهم من قصص
نجاح
تحويل حياتهم من حياه عاديه الى قصص نجاح
ناتجه عن اراده صلبه واصرار على تحقيق
الاحلام والوصول الى الاهداف من بدايه
حياتي لعمر 18 سنه عشت حياه عاديه كنت
بمشي كنت بركض كنت شاب رياضي مرصت لعبه
الكونغ فو مرسله لعبه الكاراتيه قتال
الشوارع وكنت بلعب حديد يعني نوعا ما كان
جسمي قوي
ولكن بتاريخ
30/5/2015 التاريخ اللي بقدرش انساه طول
حياتي بتعرفه ليش لانه بهذا التاريخ
انقلبت حياتي 180 درجه من قلبت للاسوء من
وجهه نظر انقلبت للاحسن انقلبت من حياه
عاديه الحياه مليئه بالتحديات والمغامرات
والنجاحات
نرجع للتاريخ
30/5/2015 بهذا اليوم قدمت اخر امتحان
تجريبي اي نعم كنت توجيهي وكنت بالمرحله
النهائيه منه كان ضايل لامتحانات التوجيهي
تقريبا شهر فقط في هذا اليوم كنت ماشي مع
اصحابي
بعد صلاه المغرب بلشت احس بوجع اسفل قدمي
بالبدايه كان وجع بسيط فقلت عضل بروح
لحاله فما اعطيته اهتمام لهيك كملت مشي
ولما اجا وقت صلاه العشاء رحنا لنصلي
العشاء انا واصحابي في المسجد بلشت اصلي
وما كنت بعرف انه هاي اخر صلاه راح اصليها
وانا واقف على رجلي
صليت بسرعه لانه كان الوجع بزيد ولما طلعت
من المسجد حكيت لاصحابي وصلوني الدار لاني
حاسس حالي تعبان وصلت الدار بصعوبه لما
وصلت الدار السلطيت على الكنبه وكان بهذا
الوقت
الوجع طلع من رجلي وصل لظهري بهذا الوقت
وبدون ما اعرف كان في حرب عنيفه حرب شرسه
في جسمي بين التهاب فيروسي وخلايا النخاع
الشوكي ما كنت بعرف انا هذا الموضوع لهيك
اعتبرت وجه عادي لكن كان شديد لهيك حبه
مسكن وحبه منوم وخف الوجع شوي ونمت
صحيت الصبح جيت بدي اقوم عادي زي ما بقوم
كل يوم لكن ما قدرت بحرك برجلي ما في حركه
نهائيا
استغربت بالبدايه استغربت حملت حالي
ساعدوني اخوتي وابوي ورحنا على المستشفى
بسرعه بالمستشفى بالبدايه استغربوا
الموضوع استغربوا كثير وما عرفوا شو السبب
اللي وصلني لهيك بس بعد كم يوم وبعد ما
عملوا لي اكثر من صوره
اكتشفوا انه في التهاب فيروسي دخل النخاع
الشوكي ووصل لاخطر منطقه في جسمي واللي هي
النخاع الشوكي تضع على اغلب الخلايا
الموجوده في اسفل العمود الفقري عندي
قضى على اغلبها مش كلها لهيك الاحساس ضل
موجود لكن الحركه راحت نهائيا
لما سمعت بهذا الحكي انصدمت صدمه كبيره
دخلت بحاله الاكتئاب عميقه قلت ليش انا
وبهذا الوقت حكولي انه حالتك هاي نادره
ونسبه حدوثها واحد على مليون قلت ليش انا
من بين مليون شخص امبارح كنت بمشي واليوم
بدون اي مقدمات صرت مقيد ومكبل بهذا
الكرسي
بهاي الفتره حزنت ودخلت بحاله اكتئاب يعني
كان وضعي مش تمام بالمره ولكن طلع من
جواتي صوت بهذا الوقت لاني توجيهي طلع من
جوات صوت بحكي لي انه امتحانات اللجنه على
الابواب وما ضللها وقت فش وقت للحزن
والاكتئاب والحكي الفاضي هذا كله هو كان
من المفترض اني اجي الامتحانات تقديم
امتحانات اللجنه للسنه اللي بعدها لكن
كمان كنت بديش اضيع تعب الدراسه اللي
تعبتوا طول السنه
لهيك صرت امام اصعب تحدي بتعرض له في
حياتي حزني على الاشي اللي صار معي من جهه
وامتحانات اللجنه اللي ما ضللها الا كم
يوم من جهه ثانيه قرات الحديث اللي بيقول
ان عظم الجزامه عظم البلاء وان الله اذا
احب قوما ابتلاهم فمن رضي فله الرضا ومن
سخط فعليه السخط وقرات الايه اللي بتقول
عسى ان تكرهوا شيئا وهو خير لكم وعسى ان
تحبوا شيئا وهو شر لكم والله لا يعلم
وانتم لا تعلمون في حديث سيدنا عمر بن
الخطاب يقول ما او بالي
لو اصبحت على ما احب او ما اكره لانني لا
ادري الخير فيما احبه او فيما اكره
هون فهمت انه الابتلاء رحمه من رب
العالمين
وانه صحيح بظاهره شر لكن في بطنه بكون في
خير كبير وانا بجزم او اكاد اجزم انه لولا
عاقتي ما وصلت اليوم للي وصلت له ارتفعت
معنوياتي بعد هذا الحكي ولقيت شويه تحفيز
وتشجيع من اهلي ومن اصحابي ومن طاقم
المستشفى كنت وقتها بجمعيه بيت لحم
العربيه للتاهيل لاخذ العلاج الطبيعي
بالمستشفى وفروا لي غرفه منفصله لادرس
فيها
وبعد هذا الشيء وبعد ما شفت هذا التحفيز
والتشجيع والاهتمام قررت اني اترك كل اشي
صار معي ورا ظهري وانا عازل بشكل كامل على
العالم الخارجي وابلش ادرس بشكل مكثف
لاقدر اعوض كل الايام اللي راحت علي
وبالفعل كنت بحصل على العلاج وبروح للغرفه
لحد ادرس بفضل الله قدمت الامتحانات
بالجامعه وبنهايه الامر حصلت على معدل
87.8 في الفرع العلمي بهذا الوقت حسيت
بلذه نجاح وانتصار ما اتوقع حس فيها
بستهزك
[تصفيق]
واخيرا وبعد ما خلصت امتحانات
بعد ما خلصت رحله علاجي رجعت للبيت لكن ما
رجعت على رجلي رجعت على الكرسي المتحرك
بهاي الفتره صار معي تحسن لكن ورجعت
الحركه لرجلي لكن الحركه اللي رجعت ما
كانت كافيه توقفني على رجلي وعلى عام امل
انه بيوم من الايام الحركه تزيد عندي
واقدر اوقف على رجلي
بعد فتره من قعدتي بالدار اجا وقت اخطار
التخصص وابلش الحياه الجامعيه بالبدايه
يعني سمعت كلام كثير انه كيف بدك تكمل
جامعه وانت بوضعك هذا كيف بدك تدرس خمس
سنين جامعه تروح وتيجي على الجامعه
مواصلات وكيف وكيف وكيف لكن كنت اطنش كل
هذا الحكي وكان في مقوله تضل ببالي انما
لا يسمع سيضطر العالم الى سماعه يوما ما
اخترت تخصص هندسه حاسوب وما كان اختياري
لهذا التخصص بمحض ايرادتي اخترته لانه
العمل بمجال الحاسوب مناسب وموائم لوضع
الصخي الصحي
وكمان اخترت جامعه البوليتكنيك لانه
الجامعه الوحيده بالخليل بتعطي تخصات
الهندسه وكان اكبر مخافه الاقي جامعه
البوليتكنيك مش موائم للكراسي المتحركه
ولكن الحمد لله
على الجامعه وبلشت دراسه كنت اتنقل بحريه
بالمباني والقاعات
واجهت بعض الصعوبات في اثناء دراستي في
الجامعه لكن تعاون طاقم الجامعه كتير
تتغلب عليها كلها ولان من لا يشكر الناس
لا يشكره الله تقدم بالشكر الجزيل لطاقم
جامعه فلسطين الاداري والاكاديمي وما بنسى
الطاقم الجميل والرائع اللي هو طاقم الامن
لانه بصراحه اكثر طاقه متعاون معي كان معي
كرسي متحرك كهربائي ما كنت اروح معي على
الدار لانه ثقيل فكنت اخليه عند الامين
لما يخلص شحن وهم يشحنوه ولما يتعطل هم
يصلحوه ويضطروا مرات يخدم سياراتهم يصلحوه
بالمحلات ربنا يجزيهم كل خير
بعد ما خلصت دراسه بكالوريوس هندسه انظمه
الحاسوب في جامعه البلوتيكنيك قررت كمان
اكمل دراسه الماجستير في الذكاء الاصطناعي
كمان في سنه
احس انها بيت الثاني بحس فيه بالامان
والطمانينه كملت دراسه الماجستير ما كملتي
انا بلشت دراسه مع العمل كمساعد بحث تدريس
في الجامعه وبعد ما اتمنت سنه من دراسه
والعمل كمساعد بحث تدريس تم بفضل الله
قبولك يا مهندس حاسوب في وزاره الاتصالات
وتكنولوجيا المعلومات
فرحت كثير اني انضميت لوزاره الاتصالات
ولكن هذا مش نهايه المشوار والحكايه بقيه
رساله اخيرا رساله للاشخاص ذوي الاعاقه لا
يستسلموا الا صغار العقول فالانسان ما دام
حيا يستطيع ان يصنع المعجزات لا تدع من
اعاقتك معيقه ان يعيقك عن تحقيق اهدافك
فانت قادر على النجاح والتفوق في اي مجال
تختاره كون الاراده والامل هم المفتاح
الرئيسي لتجاوز التحديات وتحقيق الاهداف
اجعل من اعاقتك مصدرا للقوه والالهام
تتحدى به جميع التحديات والصعوبات ولا
تنسى
[موسيقى]
والسلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته
[تصفيق]